et la rue moi je ne pense pas j'ai vu au
cours de ces dernières années et
notamment à chaque fois sur les réformes
des retraites déjà des manifestations
importantes longue qui était cette
fois-ci il y a des manifestations
pacifiques certes nombreuses mais qui
n'excèdent pas le nombre de
manifestations qu'on a vu par le passé
qui sont dans un climat sert de tension
mais qui reste dans les limites de les
dire de la non-violence et cela je dois
le saluer aujourd'hui nous croyons pas
aujourd'hui que les parlementaires ne
sont pas à l'écoute du pays moi je suis
comme Monsieur gonta ou d'autres toutes
les semaines dans ma circonscription où
je rencontre les gens les syndicats les
habitants et ce que je leur dis à moi
c'est que certes il y a une tension
aujourd'hui certes il y a mécontentement
mais ce pourquoi je suis élu c'est pour
prévoir l'avenir de ce pays après avoir
un avenir de ce pays c'est elle s'est
assuré à la fois son équilibre social
c'est garanti social et dans le même
temps son équilibre économique et que
cette loi elle est nécessaire pourquoi
parce qu'elle permettra à nos enfants à
nos petits enfants d'abord une retraite
de main une retraite descente et parce
qu'elle m'aime permettra de ne pas
endetter le pays de façon à ce que
demain comme le dit le corps aujourd'hui
bien sûr que oui aujourd'hui il y a un
équilibre des recettes mais demain les
pensions vont baisser or moi je ne veux
pas que les pensions baissent je vais
aussi que la France se sent d'être pas
plus on comprend bien que vous êtes
convaincu de la nécessité de cette
réforme des retraites mais quand on voit
que les trois quarts des Français ils
sont opposés qui a des millions de
personnes dans la rue et ce qu'il n'y
aurait pas une faille démocratique à
vouloir et bien passer par tous les
moyens cette réforme des retraites au
Parlement j'entends bien vous me citez
toujours ces mêmes chiffres qui vont
évoluer au cours du temps et je vous
rappelle que dans les mêmes chiffres 80%
des Français sont aussi convaincus que
la loi sera votée qu'elle sera appliquée
donc il y a une part de résistance de le
comprendre c'est difficile d'être une
forme de résignation
lucidité j'ai pas dit révélation j'ai
dit lucidité ils savent bien que le
régime est menacé ils savent bien qu'on
ne peut pas éternellement prendre sur
l'impôt pour payer leur tacoté il y a un
système un système qui est le système
pas répartition ou c'est les cotisants
qui payent pour les retraités c'est ça
la répartition et demain l'équilibre
démographique ne sera plus dans cette
faveur donc il faut bien aujourd'hui
travailler un peu plus pas seulement
pour assurer l'équilibre des retraites
mais aussi en travaillant plus pour
créer plus de richesses pour pouvoir
défendre les services publics les
hôpitaux la santé les écoles tout cela
ils peuvent tout cela nous devons
travailler un peu plus les Français
peuvent l'entendre aujourd'hui c'est sûr
que c'est difficile nous ne sommes pas
sourds à leur demande mais dans le même
temps je suis ici parlementaire pour
être responsable et voté pour l'avenir
de ce pays la première ministre a
reproché à la gauche énergoriale cet
après-midi d'avoir bloqué le débat au
Sénat sur la réforme des retraites
est-ce que à l'inverse on peut quand
même rappeler que le gouvernement a
utilisé la procédure dite du vote bloqué
donc il y a aussi des critiques à faire
de ce côté-là peut-être l'opposition
alors qu'elle a utilisé tous les moyens
mis à sa disposition par la Constitution
pour faire pour bloquer la discussion ne
peut pas reprocher au gouvernement
d'avoir pris les moyens nécessaires pour
éviter le blocage ce que je crois sur le
débat c'est n'a que j'ai suivi toutes
les nuits c'est que je crois que j'ai
écouté si on aurait pu en évitant les
amendements de suppression les
amendements redondants répétitifs à la
virgule etc on aurait pu avoir 2000
amendements qui traitait du fond et qui
aurait permis c'est-à-dire de purger
tous les substo tout le problème qui
aurait permis de le traiter tout
l'opposition ne l'a pas voulu et la
multiplier les amendements de procédure
n'ayant qu'un seul but à elle que le
texte ne soit pas voté nous nous
voulions qu'il y a un vote du Parlement
les parlementaires non pas seulement
pour débattre et pour présenter les
amendements mais aussi pour voter un
texte nous l'avons fait et j'en suis
satisfait vous demander à tout prix un
vote du Parlement notamment demain à
l'Assemblée nationale ou en cas de
majorité incertaine le gouvernement
devrait utiliser le 49-3 qu'est-ce que
vous je crois que c'est ce que vous
dites je crois que ce texte de loi qui
est débattu depuis quatre ans c'est pas
depuis deux mois les débattus depuis 4
ans dans le pays il y a un débat de 4
ans il y a des rencontres avec les
syndicats avec les forces vives qui ont
été multipliés qui ont abouti à des
hommes à des avances avoir des avancées
ce que j'ai toujours pensé c'est que
d'abord le phénomène le Sénat arriverait
à voter et il l'a fait je pense qu'il y
aura cette soirée une commission de
dispariteur positive et je reste
convaincu que demain il y a une grande
possibilité pour que le texte soit voté
sans 49-3 et si à l'Assemblée nationale
la majorité est incertaine est-ce que le
gouvernement doit prendre ses
responsabilités utiliser le carreau
c'est quand même une hypothèse j'espère
que ce soir tu peux toujours envisagez
le pire moi je pense aujourd'hui que
ce texte de loi arrivera à passer 149 3
merci beaucoup François Patriat François
[Musique]